[Music]
I'm here from superconductive we are the
main developers behind great
expectations the open source project
quick show of hands who here has
previously heard of great expectations
okay yeah that's actually more than I
would have thought that's great that is
wonderful a little bit about me so I'm
I'm a data scientist data engineer I've
been hands on keyboards lunging messy
datasets for a long time
when I say scientist / engineer I start
off much more on the statistics side
much more in the like figure out what
the data does side rather than in the
orchestrate the pipelines and make it
work
repeatably decide I mean I do both of
those things but for me I love human
scale data
I love understanding the stories and
data and to the point of the keynote
this morning I really like understanding
how data can be used ethically to make
the world better I'll also call out it
is weird to me but this is the first
time I've been back in New York since I
was a kid I grew up in Washington DC and
came up here a lot and then somehow just
like did not make that a habit as an
adult so it's it's good to have an
excuse to come back today I'm going to
talk about three things kind of broad
outline the first is a thing that we do
in the data community that I think is
absolutely crazy and I'm hoping to I'm
hoping to persuade you or at least get
you thinking that perhaps you're doing
the same thing and perhaps it is crazy
for you as well after that I'm going to
talk about pipeline debt it's a
technical debt in all the data pipelines
we build and when I talk about data
pipelines I don't mean exclusively ETL
or kind of sequel query type stuff I'm
thinking about data as it flows from the
top of an organization all the way down
through the bottom so machine learning
dashboards ETL of course data
transformations in the middle of data
data warehouses all of that I think of
as like various species of data
pipelines and then last like I said I'm
here representing
Great Expectations as an open-source
project and like all open-source
projects we are hungry for feedback and
hungry for good input and contributions
and I have a few specific things that
I'd love to ask the community for help
on so that's where we're going today
chapter one a thing we do that is
absolutely crazy
all right so imagine that you are not a
data engineer imagine that you're a
software engineer and the thing you do
is you build microservices and api's and
one day you build a lovely new API and
you're about to roll it out you get
together all the people who are going to
be consuming from your API and you say
ok I've got this wonderful new API and I
would love for you all to use it but by
the way there's no documentation so
you're gonna have to figure that out for
yourself and on top of that you know it
seemed I don't know hard so I didn't
test it at all
but you know it's a great API please go
ahead and by the way one last thing it's
not stable like the API I'm just pretty
sure it's gonna change at some point in
the future but I can't tell you when I
can't tell you how and I might not even
know when it changes but it's an awesome
API please go ahead please use it so if
you were a software engineer and like
this was your work product I think the
consumers of your work product would
come to you and say you are absolutely
crazy
this API that you've developed is a
prototype at best and you know I as an
engineer would be absolutely crazy to
try and build something stable on top of
this untested undocumented unstable
thing that you've got right I mean that
that's the state of the art in the
software world but in the data world
like if we flip it and we say hey I have
this lovely table in my data warehouse
it's not documented it's not tested and
it might change in the future in fact it
probably will change in the future
somehow we have all come to think of
that as like a normal state of affairs
so quick show of hands here who has run
a query on some kind of important table
or log file in the last month ok most of
us how many of those tables are that the
thing you were pointing
how many of those were fully documented
with documents that were up-to-date ooh
we've got I count three hands
oh no zero okay no that's a zero okay
two hands back down to two okay okay so
the like documentation does exist but
I'm going to assert that it is scarce
how about testing that so they're like
there's important tables you were
pointing out do they have tests on them
okay we need to talk afterwards because
you're doing something cool
let me flip around on on the stable
question who here has a story at the
organization that they currently work
for about that time that the dashboard
broke who has a story like that okay
that I've actually sink a little bit of
timidness here this is the thing right
like we're a little bit afraid to put up
our hands there cuz like oh the
dashboard broke it's sort of kind of my
fault but it's also like the fact that
we're working in a system that doesn't
have the affordances to do the things
that it keeps that it takes to keep our
systems from breaking so I put it to
that like we're kind of the frogs
boiling in the pot we've built out these
complex powerful like really interesting
data systems but in a lot of ways the
complexity of those systems and the
coolness of those systems has run ahead
of our tooling and we've wound up in a
place where we're maintaining this data
systems that are just really hard to
stay on top of and there's a lot of pain
there so 0.1 chapter one trying to
maintain a data system that is untested
undocumented and unstable is absolutely
crazy and I believe that two years from
now five years from now we will all look
back on this period and say wow I'm so
glad we got out of the dark ages because
like life is so much better when we
don't have all these fire drills and
confusion and fear around our data
systems all right now I wouldn't have
come all the way to New York for the
first time in my adult life if I didn't
have at least part of a solution to this
first step on this is I think we need to
name the monster if we're going to slay
it and the name that I want to give to
this monster is pipeline debt
I think we need to just be upfront about
the fact that there is a lot of
technical debt in our data pipelines and
I don't think that that's really I think
there's more that we can do as a
community individually but honestly I
think this mostly comes down to process
and tooling and there's some important
parts of the data tooling ecosystem that
have just been missing and the one of
course that I'm most interested in as a
core contributor is this library called
Great Expectations which is intended to
make it easy to test and document your
data pipelines and again data pipelines
is data of all kinds machine learning
models ETL data warehousing all of the
above so let me take the next few
minutes and describe to you how great
expectations works how we think about it
and kind of where it is in its lifecycle
as an open source project so we call it
great expectations because the core
abstraction is an expectation it's an
assertion about data and I'm buried here
is one really important kind of sub
point in most software engineering you
test when things change and the thing
that changes most often is the code in
the data world your code changes your
pipelines change now and then but but
actually the thing that changes much
more frequently is the data yeah I heard
a really good I need to go back and look
up the talk there's a really good line
that says in the data world most
breakages are caused by other people
whereas in the software world most
breakages are caused by yourself
so assertions about data expectations we
have things like expect a column to
exist I won't do show of hands but when
I've asked people about this like how
many pipelines have broken because a
column was renamed like stupid simple
thing and yet like that probably has
shut down a lot of people's data
pipelines and it took many hours to fix
well not to fix to find and then fix
expect the table row count to be in some
range we've got a bunch of things around
the content of the data so value should
be unique value should be not know and
let me pause we've got some nice
affordances and great expectations that
allow you to say things like well expect
them to be mostly not know
expect 95% of the values to not be null
because it turns out that in data
problems often getting to total
perfection right now just isn't
realistic but being able to say hey as
long as it's 95% clean that's good and
I'll figure out what to do with the
other 5% later regex is string time
formats right all of our favorite
problems in the data world on top of
this we have a bunch of aggregate
expectations so things like hey the
column means so like not individual rows
but like as an aggregate what should the
mean be what should that be in some
moving partition or window and then this
last one is a little bit obscure but
expect the column KL divergence to be
between this is a way of saying I've got
a reference histogram so I know like the
shape of the data last week and I want
the shape of the data continue to be the
same this week so this is just a sample
the the open source library has not
quite 50 of these expectations and
they're a rogue's gallery of all of the
like weird stuff that breaks and data
pipelines they span everything from
table and column formatting all the way
down through contents and then bordering
into things that are more statistical
anomaly detection type things and they
often in this really nice abstraction of
an expectation so just kind of diving in
with where the project is overall we
have those expectation types oh actually
I should say it's extensible to and what
we're finding is most people who are
using great expectations they start with
our library because that covers a lot of
the common cases and then they extend it
out to cover the things that are
meaningful in their ecosystem and we've
we've made that there's more we can do
to make that really easy but we've made
it easy enough that it's useful now so
we've got this concept of expectations
we also have this concept of data
sources and this is basically think of
it's like compilation targets for
expectations so initially we shipped
with pandas so you could run
expectations against pandas dataframes
the community almost immediately came
back and said hey we really want to be
able to do this in sequel so we build
great expectations out into sequel
alchemy which means that basically
anything that sequel alchemy can point
to you can run expectations against
without having to do anything special so
Postgres my sequel hive sequel server
right more recently we had a community
contribution where they built out spark
integration so spark dataframes also
have great expectations attached and
then just this week I don't know if the
folks from city block are in the room
okay hey Knight nice to meet you
so the city block team has just put in a
PR that also extends great expectations
to Google cloud store and bigquery so
we're moving forward cool stuff there
now let me pause really quickly and say
when we first shipped great expectations
this was purely a side project nobody
was working on it full-time and we had
these two concepts so expectations and
data sources it's a good start but if
you dig into it you start to notice
things like hey how do I store my
expectations and how do i schedule them
when when you know something breaks or
when an expectation returns a failure
what do I do with that like all of those
things would seem to be important parts
of building out a data validation stack
and our mode at the time was you know
kind of the complete the owl mode like
well we'll give you the circles and
you're you're halfway there to the owl
right you can build this out yourself as
we've talked to teams that have
implemented great expectations what
we've discovered is most teams that have
built out kind of a full data validation
layer we're spending at least at least a
month to get to the point where they had
something that worked reasonably well
and then there was a lot that was being
left on the table just like a lot of
other things they would have liked to
build out so I'm happy to announce that
as of the beginning of this summer we've
been working pretty full-time on great
expectations like this is a commit
history as we all know the number of
commits in a repo is a really good
indicator of progress and that
repository but like in this case it's a
decent metric so for the last few months
we've been focused on really making
great expectations a batteries included
experience and I'm excited now - for the
first time in public show you some of
the things that
have added great expectations so from an
architecture diagram perspective we have
a bunch of new words that all go in
their own boxes I'm gonna show you
generally what these things do because I
don't think the words on their own will
will mean much so first we've set up a
command line tool that makes it really
easy to initialize great expectations
it's mildly opinionated about how it
fits into version control how it stores
everything how it retrieves expectations
it has nice integrations where you can
connect to a bunch of different data
sources and that's pretty slick and then
as you see here it also allows you to
profile data sources so go through
inspect them figure out what they look
like actually build some expectations
automatically and then convert those
expectations to documentation as well so
more to get into here but but there's
some cool stuff and we've worked pretty
hard we're not done but we work pretty
hard to make this slick so that it does
not take a ton of work to finish drawing
the owl once you're set up there we have
the system set up so that it will roll
out a bunch of config files and I'm not
showing you the whole config file here
because they get kind of medium large
but but our goal is to make it so that
all of the important components of great
expectations are plugable so for example
this is the line that you need to
uncomment to activate slack web hooks so
if you want to get slack notifications
after you run validation on your
expectations great this is what you do
right you get the web hook URL you
uncomment the line and paste it in so
it's slightly reminiscent of Django or
framework like that we're trying not to
be too deeply opinionated and you can
always disconnect the underlying layer
if you want but we're also finding that
lots of people want that kind of
batteries included experience this is a
kind of short animation of you ran your
data validation you clicked on a slack
notification something was broken and
now you're clicking through to the
static website that hosts all of your
data documentation so if you look really
closely you'll notice some things that
are not beautiful about this
but in general the idea that you can
have a static website that shows you
exactly what's going on in your data
that's new it's cool it's the kind of
thing that would take a long time to
build on your own
so we're making that part of the
open-source project it just it should
just work out of the box so the thing
that we are working towards right now
and I keep hedging I keep saying it
should work we're close to we're almost
there what we want to do is we want to
get to the point where any data team can
set up their testing infrastructure in a
day or less rather than having to build
out that whole application stack for
themselves or the over the course of
months or or longer we're not quite
there and I'll say more on this in the
end we are at what I would call a
Minimum Viable Product in the sense that
like it works but has lots of rough
edges and we're actively working towards
making that minimum lovable product that
just like really really works before we
go there though let me talk about one
thing we're doing that I think is worth
mentioning in particular and and that is
this principle that your Docs are your
tests and your tests are your dogs so
great expectations because we're using
this declarative language for
expectations it turns out that you can
compile those expectations into human
readable documentation and that that's a
really nice answer to a question that
are not a question a problem that I've
seen kind of discussed and floating
around in the data engineering world
quite a bit a quick show of hands who
saw this article when it came out back
in June okay yeah you probably don't
need a data dictionary so the the case
that the authors make here which which I
think they are 99% correct on is well
I'll just lay it out you're a data
engineering team you are consuming data
from a bunch of different places and you
have a bunch of different data
stakeholders around the organization who
used the data you produce maybe they're
querying tables that you make maybe they
are looking at dashboards maybe they're
training machine learning models on top
of what you do all of those people who
consume your data are gonna be asking
you for documentation right they're
gonna say like okay what is this data
how does it work give me a data
dictionary help me understand how it
works
and the the case that the authors make
is that's really tempting and you know
these people are really gonna want it
but it's actually probably more trouble
than it's worth and the reason it's more
trouble than it's worth is because you
have a version time version time version
problem and the version time version
time version problem is different
stakeholders are going to want somewhat
different versions of the documentation
engineers are going to want to know
certain things about it non engineering
stakeholders inside your organization
are gonna want to know other things
about it people outside the organization
maybe they want to know everything but
they shouldn't be allowed to know
everything so you're going to end up
with multiple stakeholders who each end
up with a different version of a data
Docs okay so that's kind of hard to
maintain but on top of that the data is
going to change over time and the
pipeline's are also going to change over
time and in order to give people
visibility into not just how the data
works today but how it used to work and
and why those changes were made you end
up in this version time version time
version problem which is just
prohibitive it's way way way too much
work to maintain that many versions of
your data documentation unless unless
you happen to have a technology that
allows you to take your your your tests
which are being run continuously against
your data and automatically convert
those into data documentation so one of
the things that we're really excited
about great expectations is this ability
to take your your tests and keep them in
sync
always with your data dogs the way we
think of it is as long as you're running
your tests which of course you're doing
because you're not absolutely crazy
as long as you're doing that your
documentation will never go stale
because your tests are your Docs and
your Doc's are your tests so again
pretty animation that has some glitches
if you look super closely but this is
what data docks look like in Great
Expectations right now we're pushing
towards a good data view that we
flexible pluggable and allow you to do
really good descriptions that always
stay in sync with your tests all right I
hope that sounds cool I hope it's a new
idea I haven't seen anything quite like
this out there and we're really excited
about it the folks that we're working
with to like develop and deploy this are
pushing us pretty hard to make it better
fast
and again we're eager for that kind of
feedback we've got the sense that like
we're onto something here okay that said
like warning this is still quite new
there's still definitely rough edges so
what I'm trying to do is very very
definitely invite the community to
participate invite people to kind of get
involved and help us out with this but
also just make sure that you like you
don't get your fingers burned expecting
a totally polished product before we're
ready to promise that specifically if
you look at kind of the world of great
expectations
the core expectation types and the core
logic for most of the data sources is in
pretty good shape it's you know green
light data contacts this this notion of
data assets stores and validation
operators which are the things that
allow you to kick off slack messages and
do all that magic those are in pretty
good shape we've got a number of beta
users out there that like the core logic
seems pretty stable you know of course
we're building under test and doing all
those good things but you know I would
not be shocked to discover some
complications there especially
especially in the onboarding process I
think it's as a core team we're all
agreed that like we love what this looks
like when it's built but we're still
figuring out how to tell the story and
how it helped people go from you know 0
to 10 and have it be a smooth process
everywhere in between so if you've got
thoughts in our documentation love it
love love to hear those last this notion
of renderers so compiling to Docs and
profilers those are the newest part of
the the project I think there's a lot of
interesting potential there I think it
is useful today but just be warned that
that's the least stable part of
everything right now ok so what I would
like to ask specifically on this is if
there is anyone who has been looking for
a way to set up better data testing or
better data documentation like if this
is on your roadmap if it's a known pain
point for you we would love to work with
you and you know they're a bunch of
different formats this could take we're
flexible we're happy to help in any way
that it's helpful but in particular I
think it would be nice to try and take
this you know
core promise we're trying to make of
deploy in a day and do that with you so
work with us pick a day we will help you
get set up and in the meantime we'll be
looking really closely to figure out
like okay what what were the awkward
parts what were the things where our
documentation just didn't quite cover it
what were the you know where were we
missing a more informative error message
and I'm pretty sure pretty sure that if
you're working with us we'll be able to
actually get you help
like get you set up in a day and in the
process we'll learn a lot about it and
smooth the path for everybody follows
later so if this is interesting like if
it's something like to do I want to call
out I'm available and we've got three
other members of the core great
expectations team don't just raise your
hands you guys want to stand up I'm so
Eugene's over here towel and Kyle um
will be here right after the talk we're
also going to office hours and then
we've got a nice active slack channel if
this is this or anything like it is
interesting we would love to work with
you because we think that well um we're
actually pretty confident like this is a
very useful thing once you roll it out
and we want to do everything we can to
help get people over that initial hurdle
so that so we can solve this problem
once and for all
okay recap trying to maintain a data
system that is untested undocumented
unstable is absolutely crazy
and I think five years from now we're
gonna look back and say why did we ever
do it that way
thank goodness tolling finally caught up
the monsters name is pipeline debt and
once you've named it then we can slay it
to defeat pipeline debt you always need
to know what to expect of your data and
in great expectations we go straight
after that we want to get to the point
but we're not quite there yet where
anybody can set up data testing in a day
not a month your Doc's are your tests
and your tests are your Doc's there are
rough edges and if you'd like to work
with us if this sounds useful in any way
shape or form please please please come
talk to us because we're really excited
to roll this out thank you
yes Oh software engineering has concept
of mock objects and database seating
whereas it looks like great expectations
you know essentially tests against for
some form of production data you know
may be delayed a bit but I don't know do
you see any any space for like mock
datasets or whatever in yeah so usually
what I'm seeing for people who are
working with great expectations is you
want to test what's changing right and
in the data world your production data
is the thing that's changing most
frequently so that's usually where
people start because that's where most
of the pain is after that we do see a
lot of teams that will do like data
snapshots and they'll actually apply
using the same library the same kind of
tests to their code but in general you
want to test the production data first
just just because that's more of the
pain is that make sense
said yeah yeah I mean they're not
mutually exclusive
yeah it's just sort of you know what's
your priority yeah just curious if
there's any provisions or anything in
short future for dealing with privacy
and trying to track for example if there
are sensitive data sets for there to be
assets asad some of the the UI do you
have your examples of data whereas there
could be some issues there just your
thoughts on that yeah so that's a great
question
we're to be honest it comes up often
enough that I know we're gonna have to
figure out how to how to deal with that
how to work with it there's another
thing that shows up in parallel a lot
which is you often have large data sets
that have many columns or just like lots
of complexity to them and what we're
seeing is a lot of teams say hey I don't
want to deal with all 400 columns at
once I just want to like check the
twenty that matter the most and zero in
on that so there's no this notion of
like importance flagging and also kind
of privacy and protection flagging those
seem to be parallel concepts and yeah
we're actively exploring how to think
about those whether that should be
a different flag or its own kind of
expectation or something else in the
system
and I will say like the system's
flexible enough as it is that you can
kind of hack around that pretty easily
you can kind of develop your own tool
link there but it's not a thing that we
we don't want to be opinionated about
that until we're confident that are the
opinion we're expressing generalizes
really well to most cases so this looks
really interesting
for documenting things for the kind of
more technical parts of the organization
on the business side in one of the
challenges that I face is you know there
can be 10 different flavors of revenue
for instance and maybe the boss wants to
look at one of those everybody wants
documentation it is the class of problem
as you said to keep that up to date is
it's really hard is there any is there
any is there any any part of great
expectations that helps you with that
sort of higher level documentation even
if it's just sort of adding comments on
top of you know what the sort of
auto-generated statistical description
is in Part B if I can ask that you know
sometimes these things really make sense
in a broader context where it's not just
one object or one table but but how they
interrelate and it's impossible to say
well if things are going really well I
should be able to take this view in this
view and this should be the relation
between those two yeah so the answer on
both of those is yes we definitely I
would say today we enable that but again
it's not not fully batteries included we
we think that a lot of value for great
expectations is to get into this like
semantically rich meaningful layer and
not just describe things in terms of
schemas and formats but to be able to
actually bridge between roles so when I
talk about multiple stakeholders who
won't all want different kinds of
documentation knowing like which revenue
calculator was used to calculate that
statistic like that's exactly the kind
of thing that we want to enable like I
can't tell you how much of my life I
have spent trying to figure out why
denominators are different into two
statistics
and that's exactly the kind of thing
that like should be covered as more data
provide systems come under better
documentation so if you want to talk
more about that afterwards and and this
goes for everybody I love to engage in a
deeper conversation
are you doing first and foremost this
looks really awesome I had a question
about under the hood it looks like
you're using like sequel alchemy what
can you say a little bit more about what
went into that selection process my
company is using we built out a package
similar to this and we used like Python
parser to kind of look at tokenization
our use case was different we're doing a
lot of intake so we want to be able to
sit through different structure and be
able to parse that way yeah the short
version is for us we need to basically
be able to hear I'll scroll back we need
to be able to compile these concepts
down and compile it's Python it's not
really compilation but convert these
these kind of semantically meaningful
concepts into something that'll run
against sequel and of course the sequel
isn't a single target there are lots of
different sequel dialects out there we
didn't want to get into the world of
ourselves
writing translators to each of those
dialects and so sequel alchemy and
specifically the sequel alchemy core not
the full ORM I think unless somebody
knows otherwise unless there's some new
hotness out there that I haven't heard
about it's the single best kind of close
to universal translator that we have in
the Python ecosystem so you know if
you're looking at that and figuring that
yes this like will basically accomplish
what we're trying to do it was a pretty
easy choice for us
[Music]